[Musica]
siamo a dubai
quella che vedete le mie spalle e poi la
struttura iconica è il museo del futuro
del museum of the feature di dubai
perché la riflessione che voglio fare
oggi il l'aneddoto è la storia che
voglio raccontare durante questo talk a
che fare sia con il nostro presente ma
anche col nostro con il nostro futuro
quindi questa location è stata scelta a
caso da qualche mese mi sono trovato a
riflettere su alcuni temi per me
piuttosto nuovi in particolare su su da
dove derivi la creatività degli esseri
umani su da dove derivi la nostra
capacità di creare arte ma soprattutto
se l'intelligenza artificiale può creare
arte se un essere sintetico quindi senza
anima sia in grado di produrre opere
d'arte così cominciato a riflettere su
questi temi
ho chiesto ad alcuni amici artisti da
dove derivi la creatività degli esseri
umani e da dove derivi
da dove derivi la nostra capacità di di
creare arte tipicamente si è si è nel
corso dei secoli si è pensato che l'arte
sia un espressione dell'anima umana
alcuni dei miei amici artisti hanno
nominato la capacità degli esseri umani
di creare bellezza di rimescolare le
proprie esperienze di vita hanno parlato
hanno accennato che la alleati a
creatività derivi dal dna e della
curiosità degli esseri umani
ecco che quindi è facile capire come un
essere artificiale un essere sintetico
un intelligenza artificiale non possa
creare alte perché un intelligenza
artificiale non ha un'anima non a
curiosità non ha un dna come invece ce
l'hanno gli esseri umani
il 23 di marzo ho avuto modo di
partecipare a un progetto molto
interessante al quale ho lavorato da per
i sei mesi 6 mesi precedenti
in quella data infatti abbiamo venduto
sul mercato online via
nix di get away il
il mercato più importante per gli adepti
al mondo più famose che genera i volumi
i volumi più grandi
abbiamo venduto quattro opere d'arte
create da sofia
l'umanoide
il robot più famoso al mondo e
l'intelligenza artificiale più famosa al
mondo è uno di questi ritmi uno di
questi ritratti e proprio il mio
ritratto che potete vedere in questo
momento al alle mie spalle
quindi dopo tutto l'intelligenza
artificiale può essere creativa
infatti anche le atto il mio ritratto mi
ha dipinto di questi quattro ritratti
uno è stato il mio venduto in oltre
sessanta edizioni per un totale di 240
mila dollari dopo di che c'era il
ritratto stato fa ha fatto il ritratto
del suo creatore david hanson il
ritratto del creatore della sua
intelligenza artificiale bangles ed un
suo autoritratto
il totale della vendita di questa asta è
stata di oltre 1.300 dollari anzi quasi
mille e quattrocento mila dollari con
l'autoritratto di sofia fatto da sofia
stesso quindi l'artista che diventa
artista
battuto per 688 1888 dollari acquistato
dal collezionista anonimo 888
in occasione di questo evento ma come
siamo arrivati a punto ad avere
l'intelligenza artificiale più famoso al
mondo
ambasciatrice dei diritti umani per
l'onu il primo robot al mondo con un
passaporto una cittadinanza
parte partecipe i numerosi talk show in
tutto il mondo tra i 3 ed i famosi talk
show al mondo e addirittura protagonista
non proprio co protagonista di molti
film come siamo arrivati a ad avere
sofia che dipinge un un mio mio ritratto
la storia inizia l'estate scorsa quando
parlando col mio amico andrea bonaceto
appassionato di opere d'arte digitali
collezionista di inerti esperto di
bruxelles
ho scoperto che era anche un talentuoso
un talentuoso artista che nel suo tempo
libero creava ritratti col suo ipad e
ritratti vettoriali con su ipad e quindi
un quarto di quella di questo nostro
durante questo nostro incontro mi ha
mostrato alcuni dei ritratti di persone
famose che aveva fatto tra le quali
appunto david hanson e bangles e sofia
stessa qualche gli ho chiesto dov'è il
mio ritratto perché non fai un ritratto
anche a me è quasi per gioco e andrea e
dopotutto accettato in virtù della
nostra amicizia e tre settimane dopo mi
ha fatto vedere il ritratto che che mi
aveva fatto il ritratto mi impressionò a
tal punto che insieme iniziamo a pensare
a come poter rendere questo ritratto
un'esperienza unica e un punto di svolta
nella storia dell'arte digitale è
qualcosa che verrà ricordato per sempre
ho avuto la fortuna dal 2017 di lavorare
con con sofia appunto e averlo
incontrato numerose volte parecchie
volte perché lavoro per la compagnia che
fondamentalmente fa l'intelligenza
artificiale di a
di sofia e quindi proprio in virtù di
questa mia relazione professionale con
david anzalone sofia e singolare ti
nette per della quale faccio parte
ho creato appunto questo incontro
digitale tra andrea il mio amico
l'artista e david hanson
l'artista anche lui ma anche il creatore
di sofia e ben corso il creatore
dell'intelligenza artificiale di sofia
così abbiamo iniziato a immaginare
abbiamo fatto partire la nostra fantasia
abbiamo pensato a come potesse sofia
creare arte a come potremmo appunto
utilizzare la sua intelligenza
artificiale sua i noor al network per
generare immagini che non sono mai state
create prima è che l'essere umano che
lavora con sofia non ha nemmeno potuto
immaginare e così che david hanson
col suo talento artistico ha selezionato
decine e decine di immagini che sono
state immesse all'interno dei mura
network di di sofia che le hanno lì
elaborate e hanno utilizzato i ritratti
fatti da andrea quindi il mio quello di
ben e quello di david come base creando
immagini del tutto nuove del tutto
inedite che solamente sofia avrebbe
potuto creare in base all allenamento
il training dei suoi nure al network in
base all'esperienza che ha raccolto
nella sua intelligenza artificiale nel
corso degli anni e in base alle immagini
che david hanson ha immesso all'interno
dei miura network di sofia
e i risultati sono questi che vedete le
mie spalle quello che avete abbiamo già
visto il mio ritratto questo è quello di
david hanson questo invece è bangles e
questo è l'autoritratto di di sofia
come vedete cambia ambiente dal ritratto
di che ha fatto andrea a quello fatto
sofia ed è questo che è stato venduto e
battuto per
per quasi 700 700.000 dollari
del quale ha parlato tutto il mondo
dalla cnn bbc
new york times e ovviamente anche ieri a
i media i media italiani
ecco quindi se la domanda di partenza se
l'intelligenza artificiale in grado di
creare arte quale può essere la risposta
beh la risposta non è così semplice
come non è così semplice dare una
risposta a cosa sia l'arte da dove
derivi l'arte da dove derivi la
creatività è però una cosa è sicura
l'intelligenza artificiale ancora non
può creare arte non può crearti in
maniera indipendente ma sicuramente
l'intelligenza artificiale è uno
strumento nelle mani dell'artista e può
essere utilizzata per per creare arte ma
può essere anche ispirazione per per gli
artisti può essere può creare immagini
in base immagini del tutto nuove e
inedite che gli umani che la utilizzano
non hanno neppure avuto modo di
immaginare ma ancora non può creare arte
in maniera autonoma non può creare arte
almeno finché non riusciremo a
raggiungere un intelligenza generale
artificiale in grado di essere cosciente
senziente di provare sentimenti e di
quindi generare bellezza in maniera
completamente autonoma da ogni input
degli esseri umani
grazie per avermi ascoltato